hey guys I'm back and I wanted to do a
slightly different video from what I
normally do
I think 95% of my content on YouTube is
just purely chess for a good reason but
I'm also really into photography and
photo editing and if you haven't seen my
previous video I'm in the nosce Spain
right now very small mountain town but
really nice scenery and I wanted to do
some some photo editing and just edit a
few couple photos I took over the last
last day I've only been here for about
24 hours
and I'm staying at the hotel right now
with a really nice view his one window
in my hotel room if people can see this
but there's a window and the view is
just incredible it's probably the best
view I've ever had at any hotel that
I've stayed in and I've taken a couple
photos one photo actually this one I
took just like 10 minutes ago with my my
Canon camera and show my Canon here 5d
mark ii fisheye lens and another photo I
took last night during a pretty bad
thunderstorm caught some lightning this
was a 20 second exposure and the
lightning lightning was a bit sporadic
but I did manage to get a couple shots
with these lightning bolts so what I'm
gonna do is just go through the editing
process all the photos that I take at
least with my my professional camera I
shoot in RAW as opposed to JPEG and this
gives a lot more kind of editing editing
opportunities as it preserves more
detail and it will allow me to to make
the photo really pop as we'll see so I'm
just gonna walk through kind of the
editing process go through color
exposure etc I don't know how much
commentary I'm gonna give but we'll
start with the exposure and usually a
photo like this I just want to bring out
more detail like the sky
bring down the highlights bring up the
shadows and the foreground usually with
photos it would like some white points
anything that's highlighted here is a
true white point or true whites so just
a little bit of true whites a little bit
of true black we're gonna boost up the
clarity sharpen the image a little bit
boost up the vibrance and even with just
some simple edits it's looking pretty
nice this is before and after I'll keep
going here the color functionality is is
really nice in Lightroom because I can
target each different color and then
affect the saturation and the luminance
so that's what I'll do I'll start with
lip blues in the sky
I'll saturate them just a little bit I
don't want to go too extreme even though
that looks kind of kind of interesting
and just do it very subtle here same
thing with the greens and the yellows
and the oranges just making it top a bit
more I don't know if I want to brighten
or darken the blues darken a little bit
probably brighten the greens yeah the
the green and the mountains I want to
kind of accentuate the these kind of
patches of sunlight oranges and yellows
I'll probably be darkened a little bit
and this is looking nice we just wanted
to see the color effects this is before
affecting the color isn't after split
toning is another option which I don't
mess around with too often I'm gonna do
a little bit here just to effect the
highlights I want a bit more warmth but
not too much and then a bit cool cool
tones and the shadows so before after
that's very subtle but I'll leave it as
is sharpening I'll boost up a little bit
zoom in here sharpening usually goes up
to like its 1890
we only only want areas to be sharp that
have details I'm going up I'm asking
and only the white areas are affected so
the only the areas with detail well
something like that and that doesn't
really make a difference when it zoomed
out but if I were to make a large print
I would want some additional sharpness
of people concede before before after
it's actually some noticeable difference
okay so this is before and after so far
I think I'll put a vignette just because
it's a fisheye and just such a wide
angle I want the focus to be in the
center so just a very subtle vignette
and the feathering bring highlights all
the way up this is a full image this is
a full image and I'm liking the way this
looks and this is just like all the
basic Lightroom adjustments I could do a
little bit more
I might experiment a bit further with
some some radial filters these are
always pretty cool to do specialized
areas let me just demonstrate let me you
add juice I don't want this I want this
I mean I had just just want like a spot
of sunlight maybe around here
Booth's exposure invert this something
very subtle boosah warmth shadows go up
use some clarity and makes a bit smaller
and we can duplicate this and I'll
create a few of these for out the image
where do I want this maybe here bring it
down so it's very subtle but it just
accentuates kind of the areas that have
been hit with the Sun a bit more I'm
liking the way this looks
I could do a few more things maybe bring
a create a filter like this just to put
more emphasis on the the center of the
image sharpness can go down here and
then shadows go down clarity can go down
anyway there's infinite ways to play
around here I've I could spend maybe 10
20 more minutes but I'll try and keep
this brief so so there we go this is
before this is after and what I want to
do is is have this image side by side
with the Lightning image just to show
the contrast in weather so let's move on
go to the other image lightning shot and
this one the composition wasn't as good
I was kind of just balancing the the
camera on the windowsill and it had a
lower angle and there's a long exposure
as a 20 second exposure I probably took
good like 20 to 30 photos until I got
the lightning that I wanted and for this
one will do a significant amount of
editing I start by cropping this just to
get rid of the top framing can crop in
pretty far here I do want to keep the
home this kind of on the side so maybe
crop out just a bit something like this
and yeah well do similar things will
drop down the highlights bring up the
shadows so now I have detail in the very
dark areas which is great about Roth oh
that was like Roth fo does preserve
detail in spots where JPEG would
probably just not have the same type of
detail I want to bring up the lights
really want to accentuate the lightening
I'll bring down the exposure bringing
down the exposure affected the darker
areas might try and fix that later bring
up the clarity add some vibrance maybe
bring down the blacks not too much so
this is oops oh I had edited this before
so it's showing before photo let me make
a virtual copy virtual copy I just want
to be able to show the before and after
okay I'm just gonna reset okay so this
is before and I believe this is after
bringing us back so before after haven't
really done too much fudge we'll keep
going
the color is interesting here because
the sky is blue but the lightning is
purple so what I want to do is bring
down the Blues a good amount maybe you
can saturate the Blues a little bit and
then bring up the purple saturate the
purple magenta would ever bring up the
purple magenta and just with the colors
it's a it's a nice transition more
contrast in the sky one of the issues
here is these like dirt spots on the
lens and this is a nice feature in
Lightroom I can just basically remove
the spots with a click so I'm going to
go around and click and there's a good
amount of these spots one of the issues
with the fisheye lens can pick up
everything anymore dirts up here a
little bit if I had more time and I want
it to be a lot more precise I could kind
of go through make sure all the dirt is
cleaned up oops
don't want to do that for now it's
looking decent most of the dirt at least
some big dirt spots are gone okay so
this is before this is after let's go
down here and play
around a bit more I can bring the
yellows up so lights of the city I'll
sharpen a bit I do want the lightening
to be sharp like that and I'm gonna add
if in yet just to put even more emphasis
on the lightening and feather it a
little bit and I'm gonna do some some
selective filters similar to the last
photo I want to brighten the kind of the
homes in the the foreground so I'm going
to add a a radial filter its radial no
it's graduated whatever forget what we
call this and just brighten like this
parts and I am aware that some people I
don't know are critical of this sort of
type of photo editing because I'm I'm
taking a photo and maybe making it a bit
more fake but I'm trying just to get the
best possible image out of the raw file
and this is pretty standard in when it
comes to to processing RAW photos so
this is already looking nicer because
now there's some some brightness on the
side here I want to bring the clouds
down I want to make the clouds much
darker so I'm going to add one more
filter it's bringing the clarity up and
we're gonna DA's D haze has a nice
effect now when I D haze it brings out
more of lens dirt which I'll probably
have to fix can bring the lights down
even more okay I don't want to go too
extreme this is looking nice and go in
clean up some more dirt yeah there's a
lot of these annoying spots probably
just have to clean my lens or clean the
camera sensor or whatever
okay I do apologize for people who might
find this boring but if you're still
watching that's probably a good thing
there's one more spot which is annoying
me yeah I'm a bit of a perfectionist
when it comes to this type of photo
editing just right there
okay I'm not going to worry too much
this is looking nice this is before
after you can really see the power of
the RAW processing I want to do maybe a
couple more things I do want to add a
filter here with the lightning make it
maybe even a bit more purple or even
maybe I can make the whole image a bit
more purple magenta let's do this first
yeah too much something like that and
then I'll go back to the filter add a
filter like this it already exists bring
up the purple invert now I do want it to
be big I want to feather it as much as
possible I don't want too much magenta
something like that maybe up the
exposure up the contrast to just so the
lightening stands out even more so
before after this is looking nice I
might even add like one more one more
graduated filter like this and what did
i do there there we go
just bring the foreground a little bit
had some clarity
I keep going back and forth between the
photo I originally edited but this is
before this is after I'm I'm pleased
with this uh there's I guess some more
more touch-ups I can do if I want to
lighten this part maybe bring up the
exposure here just so some of the lights
can be reflected on the roof here so
before after yeah I'm not gonna play
around too much more really the point of
this video is just to give people an
idea of the process of editing photos
kind of the nature of applying selected
filters and using the functionality of
Lightroom and this is really just an
experimental video to doing it's
completely different content to what I
usually do but if you guys enjoy this
let me know and I'll do more of it if
you guys don't enjoy it I'll probably
won't do more of it at some point I was
debating whether to make a channel like
devoted to photo editing but yeah I'll
see I'll listen to the feedback and see
what people think but anyway just to
wrap things up let's go back to the grid
view I will get rid of this for now just
remove it so these are the two really
this is the same view from my window but
two completely different scenes
depending on the weather
yeah it's a nice view and this is my
home for the next the next ten days so
I'm gonna leave it at that
I hope you guys enjoyed that and I'm
going to be trying to upload more more
content throughout the this event but
we'll see how it goes so let me pause
this and I'll see you guys in the future